دعونا نلقي نظرة على ما قاله مكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي هنا
كان هناك شخص مهتم بأنه
كان هناك اشتباه في وجود سعودي يعيش في
لوس أنجلوس يشتبه في أنه
عميل استخبارات سعودي عمر البيومي
وأنه عندما قام اثنان من الخاطفين 911 ،
نواف الحازمي وحليد آل.
وصلت ميثا إلى لوس أنجلوس ، حيث لم
يتحدثوا الإنجليزية حقًا وكانوا بحاجة إلى
المساعدة والدعم ، وما
أفرج عنه مكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي في الوثائق يقول
أنهم كانوا يتلقون دعمًا ماليًا من
بيومي أنهم كانوا يتلقون دعمًا
للترجمة للإقامة
ورحلات الطيران وهم و
قال مكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي أيضًا وسأقرأ هذا لك فقط
لأن التفاصيل مهمة هنا
لما يقولونه لأن هذا
يعزز اعتقادهم بأن بيومي
كان يتصرف لصالح ومع الحكومة السعودية
في ربط هذين
الخاطفين اللذين سيذهبان
ليطيروا بطائرتهم إلى البنتاغون ، هذا ما يقوله مكتب
التحقيقات الفيدرالي أنهم يقولون
إنه بعد شهر واحد تقريبًا من 9 11
هناك خط منقح هنا منقح للزوجة السابقة
تمت مقابلة إد
وقالت إنها التقت بيومي عدة مرات وأن
بيومي كانت تتحدث دائمًا عن
حاجة المجتمع الإسلامي لاتخاذ إجراءات
أخبرها وزوجها
بحذف اسمها في عدة مناسبات
من الجهاد ، وهذا هو الدليل على
أن مكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي لديه  أفرج عن
وثيقتهم لا تزال منقحة بشدة
. قال وزير الخارجية السعودي للتو
إنه يرحب بإصدار هذه
الوثائق الجديدة من قبل مكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي الذي يقول
إن الحكومة السعودية كانت
تدعو إلى ذلك لبعض الوقت ، ويقول
إنه من المهم التركيز على الوضع الحالي.
محاربة الإرهاب العالمي يقول إن
السعوديين هم شريك
للمجتمع الدولي في ملاحقة
هؤلاء الإرهابيين ، وقد رفض السعوديون على الدوام
المزاعم والاعتقاد
بأن بيومي كان عميلاً للحكومة السعودية
يعمل لصالح الحكومة السعودية
تدفق الأموال التي  تم
اقتراح الذهاب إليه من
المسؤولين السعوديين وانتهى الأمر بدعم اثنين
من هؤلاء الخاطفين أمر أساسي لذلك
هذه التفاصيل الجديدة أه أسر
أه ضحايا هجوم 911 قالوا
إنهم يرحبون بهذه التفاصيل الجديدة ،
إنهم محبطون من مستوى
التنقيح ، لذلك يبدو أن هذه
الخطوة التي اتخذتها
العملية
لم تكن كذلك  تغيروا إلى موقف الحكومة السعودية
بأنهم يرفضون أن يكون
هذا من خلال "بومي" المركزية لهذا أنهم من خلاله
كانوا يساعدون الخاطفين الذين يرفضون
ذلك.